SPYMASTER TO TAKE OVER AT THE
AGENCY AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER IT WOULD BE A WOMAN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK TONIGHT AT
GINA HASPEL.
WHO IS SHE?
HERE IS NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER GRIFFIN
LIVE FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> THERE ARE FEW IMAGES OF GINA
HASPEL, A CAREER INTELLIGENCE
OPERATIVE, WHO WORKED IN THE
SHADOWS LEADING THE HUNT FOR THE
WORLD'S MOST WANTED TERRORIST.
LAST MARCH AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE CIA, SHE SET TWO SEATS DOWN
FROM DEFENSE SECRETARY JIM
MATTIS HAS HE WELCOMED THE SAUDI
CROWN PRINCE TO THE PENTAGON.
SHE WOULD BE THE FIRST WOMAN TO
HAVE THE AGENCY IF CONFIRMED.
SHE IS 61 AND WAS ONCE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
CLANDESTINE SERVICE.
SHE OVERSAW COVERT ACTION AND
RAN THE CIA BLACK SITE IN
THAILAND.
>> SHE HAS SOMEONE UP TO HER
EYEBALLS IN THE TORTURE ISSUE.
SHE WAS IN CHARGE OF THE CIA
TORTURE SITE IN THAILAND, A
PLACE WHERE ONE MAN WAS WATER
BOARDED 83 TIMES.
>> HASPEL ORDERED THE
DESTRUCTION OF WATERBOARDING
TAPES.
ACCORDING TO HER BOSS WHO WROTE
ABOUT IT.
"THE CABLE LEFT NOTHING TO
CHANCE.
IT TOLD THEM HOW TO GET RID OF
THE TAPES.
THEY WERE TO USE AN
INDUSTRIAL-STRENGTH SHREDDER."
HASPEL'S DEFENDERS SAY THOSE
BLACK SITES HAVE TO BE SEEN IN
CONTEXT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
PRESIDENT BUSH AUTHORIZED THE
ACTIONS.
THE CIA BELIEVED AT THE TIME THE
U.S. WAS FACING ANOTHER MAJOR
ATTACK AND THAT WAKE OF 9/11.
>> GINA SOMEONE I HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN.
HAVING A PROFESSIONAL, HAVING
SOMEONE WHO IS NONPARTISAN AND
IS NOT GOING TO ENGAGE IN POLICY
WILL BE SEEN AS A BREATH OF
FRESH AIR.
>> TRUMP SPOKE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN ABOUT REINSTATING
WATERBOARDING.
FEW IN THIS EA WOULD NOW
SUPPORTED.
MEMBERS OF THE PARAMILITARY
COMMITTEE HAVE WELCOMED HASPEL'S
NOMINATION.
DEFENSE SECRETARY JIM MATTIS IS
A BIG PROPONENT AS WELL.
>> Bret: WITH ALL OF THIS
HAPPENING, WHILE SECRETARY
MATTIS IS IN KABUL, AFGHANISTAN,
INTERESTING.
>> SECRETARY MATTIS IS TALKING
ABOUT HOW THE MILITARY STRATEGY
IS PROCEEDING AND WHETHER THE
AFGHAN PRESIDENT BELIEVES
RECONCILIATION TALKS WITH THE
TALIBAN COULD WORK.
YOU WILL REMEMBER THE TALIBAN
WROTE AN OPEN LETTER TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC SUGGESTING AS
MUCH ON VALENTINE'S DAY.
>> ALL WARS COME TO AN END.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS AN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE YOU WEREN'T
ALERTED TO THE OPPORTUNITY.
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE DOOR OPEN,
EVEN AS YOU INCREASE THE
MILITARY PRESSURE.
>> 17 YEARS INTO THE WAR AND
THEY DEFENSE SECRETARY STILL
TRAVELS TO KABUL IN SECRET.
REPORTERS WERE UNABLE TO REPORT
UNTIL SAFELY AWAY FROM THE
FLIGHT LINE.
IN SEPTEMBER THE TALIBAN FIRED
40 ROCKETS AT A U.S. AIR BASED.